[Música]
aquí
ahí
lo que tiene han vendido dos amigos con
la vida de nicaragua pero resulta que
nosotros no tenemos la posibilidad
vendiendo todo lo que tenemos todos
juntos no nos da países no se va
apreciando por nicaragua entonces lo que
hicimos realmente fue una imposición de
bajo costo una construcción de bajo
coste con una cámara un neumático de un
tractor esto se lo tenía un plástico con
espuma es un pedacito de sogas y toda
sola más ram como quien dice nos tiramos
[Música]
yo solo
en todo sentido
pero fueron los días más tristes de
todos nosotros si ellos sufrieron en el
mal más sufrimos nosotros aquí que le
estábamos pidiendo que nos protegiera a
todos ellos porque ellos no aparecían
por mi mente
[Música]
ah
no podíamos acercarnos porque el mal
tiempo no dejaba y eran unas olas del
hombre
y todos le pedimos a dios le pedimos a
todos que nos estuviera escuchando ahí
arriba y no estábamos cuando amanecimos
por la mañana estábamos pegado a las
aguas de eeuu
eso fue una cosa increíble
[Música]
pero bueno se va a poner el ejemplo